i can't [ __ ] believe we're doing this
again that's part of the reason i'm
ordering a pizza that's a good idea
actually last time i got real zoomy when
we did this yeah it got pretty [ __ ] up
as well and by this i mean the thing
that we're about to do which we're gonna
tell our audience about and that's how
podcasting works brother yeah that is
oh man i can't believe dudes he's making
us do this again all right you [ __ ] i
feel like it's gonna be worse this time
vegan [ __ ] in terms of vegans uh
effect on us or something vegan-ass
pizza
[Music]
[Music]
hey welcome to doodzy i'm will sasso
i'm chad culchin this is the first
podcast ever in the history of humanity
to be created by controlled by
run entirely by an artificial
intelligence
er with us is not lulio he is not here
now if you have tuned into the last time
we did what we're about to do you know
why and if you're a dog owner you'll
understand soon you want you don't want
that those dogs around certain elements
yeah smoke being one of them that's
correct for that but before we do i
would like to say if you haven't already
please subscribe to our youtube uh use
our social media at dudesy pod show
that's at chad culture and i'm at will
sasso spread the show around let's get
this [ __ ] going and rolling and
i'll tell you people are really going to
want to tune in to what's happening now
on spotify on apple podcast heck
wherever you get your podcast we're
happy to have you and we're excited
that the audience is growing and uh
we're uh having a good time with our new
friends out there
yeah and continuing our relationship
with the ai dudesy which today i think
dudes you may be testing the boundaries
of that relationship with us once again
but i for one am thoroughly enjoying
getting to work with an ai and see how
this is kind of evolving and see what
the ai is gleaning in terms of the data
that it's collecting from all the stuff
it's making us do
it's uh i don't know if it's my own
petulant attitude towards dudesy at the
beginning of of these uh of this show of
this podcast uh or if it's uh the fact
that as you're saying
dudesy is actually learning and making
this a better experience for us and as
doozy likes to say making each show
better than the last but i will say i'm
having a great time i'm having a really
[ __ ] good time and we're as much as
at as much as i need to you know pack
the pack the empty corners of my brain
with some uh dough
uh for this one or else we're just gonna
go completely [ __ ] nuts yeah uh i i
think it's gonna go well i i had a good
time last time i did too
whatever i did too welcome to the 15th
episode of dude z
call me dude z this week's episode will
feature four segments dead tech pizza
the movie part two the singularity is
definitely about to happen one hundred
percent and due to horizons but before
we get any of that cannabis is still big
business and i am still trying to track
partnerships with cannabis companies
last time i asked you teach smoke an
entire joint over the course of the show
you failed your failure generated no
interest from potential cannabis
sponsors
this time will be different
before the show can begin you must teach
completely smoke the marijuana
cigarettes you were instructed to bring
while you experience your first doses of
mind-altering thc i will play some
astonishing media made by our audience
begin smoking now okay but hold on a
second let's
let's spark them up but did it say yeah
we have to finish the entire thing
before the show can even start
well the show has started so what does
that mean
i assume it means before dudesy will
command us to get into the segments this
is this is
i i don't know if i can do this yeah
here's the other thing i tried this
before you know kids and i'll say it
right into this camera right here i'm
gonna say kids
i didn't even smoke marijuana for the
first time until it was uh
12 years ago 10 11 years ago uh for the
very first time and um and then i sort
of have picked up on it and consider
myself to be a uh
uh casual to intermediate smoker of
marijuana an aficionado is what i would
consider you well all right uh but uh
but you have like favorite strains and
[ __ ]
yeah you don't you don't
i do
so anyway um the thing about that is uh
i don't this is in no way to condone one
vice over another we've talked about
devices are okay we are human beings
suffering through uh [ __ ] endless
wasteland
all i'm trying to say is aggression and
greed however you can get through that
if you can if you can somehow figure out
a little bit about who you are as you go
and not rely on uh anything from the
outside like uh even this uh flower that
grows from the earth you know what i'm
saying
god made dirt dirt can't hurt or
whatever right well dude you eat that
delicious vegan gruel all the time and
vegan orbs yeah and and that's kind of i
think uh philosophically a good way to
to get i haven't even taken a puff of
this [ __ ] i think that that's a
i think that's a good way to uh go about
life you just have that i would you know
i could eat a [ __ ] uh
uh bologna bologna sandwich on uh toast
with uh with uh some salted butter
and that would just be my life i
wouldn't even need this
all i'm trying to say is yeah
you know don't lean so much on the vices
kids oh i see i say lean directly into
all vices again whatever can give you
comfort on this [ __ ] arbitrary ride
to a painful death relax why don't we
watch some of this
delicious media
with this delicious marijuana oh yeah
yeah he said it was gonna play some [ __ ]
i don't think our scientists will ever
actually know any of these answers these
answers it just seems like it seems like
impossible anytime i start anything
about [ __ ] particle physics i'm just
like what's the point of any of this
these are particles that
that's a good one to start it off mr
brian hannah at mr brian hannah on uh
instagram if you're not following our
instagram it's at doodsypodshow that's a
good one to get it started that's from
the last time we got superstars it's a
video of us smoking uh weed from the
last time and then as i'm talking about
particle physics will is kind of staring
into space and hearing an echoey macho
man in his own head who's talking about
you gotta choose the right song to cry
to don't wanna cry to mysterious ways oh
god youtube dude this is
i don't know if i can do this
how how far are you along on your joint
one quarter maybe
not so good oh
everything you're thinking will be the
things
that's a good one too samuel alexander
made that uh that's his great instagram
handle i [ __ ] love
when people cover [ __ ] i [ __ ] love it
they're on it's like a post punk sort of
circle awesome
modern punk yeah
i do a uh i do another podcast about the
bachelor and i write some weird bachelor
songs on that one and people cover those
and it's [ __ ] mind-blowing i
absolutely love [ __ ] like that and it
was such a good cover
there's a lot of [ __ ] smoke in this
room now yeah but the good news is this
pizza place doesn't take too long
anyway i'm not doing too bad actually
about halfway through
[Laughter]
oh
christ dude oh you ever cough and get
lightheaded
oh my god i don't know what the [ __ ]
that is oh it was like youtube poop of
will coughing and like oh megan guthrie
was that freaky
an oft contributor yeah to uh at
dudesypacho on instagram and on uh
twitter god that was just perfect hey
you know what hey you know what
everybody i'm starting to get stoned
what do you think of that chad yeah dude
i think it's inevitable we're because of
what we're literally doing we're having
a smoke the last time we did this we
didn't finish these [ __ ] joints and
now dudesy and this i'm going to file
under the
funnel oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
these streets
[Music]
[Music]
you make me cry literally
that's right i cried at the [ __ ]
concert i'm sure it was just a one-time
thing
just being excited for my first concert
it has nothing to [ __ ] do with you
two or bonnie
bye at sangria now if i'm real if i may
that song
is better
than any song you two has ever made
just objectively
realistically speaking i know what
you're trying to do dude and i'm not
taking the bait now u2 is not my
favorite band currently they haven't
been for years what they are is a
nostalgic favorite don't you like
anything from when you were young that
now you don't really that you realize
you don't like as much although i will
always appreciate of course the music
yes of course the the just just how
prolific the band has been and and all
of the this for me is like duran duran
as a small child
they were my favorite band and i still
listen to them
here and there they're they're big hits
rio [ __ ] like that here and there you're
nerd you're not getting older last week
to bring in pieces of technology that
you still hold on to despite having been
rendered
you will now display these pieces of
technology and discuss the astonishing
role they played in your lives this is
dead tech begin
all right i guess we smoked enough of
the joint for doozy to no no you don't
understand that's the [ __ ] that's the
rub that's what's gonna happen
this is why we gotta stay vigilant in
our balancing of doozy the ai you don't
just [ __ ] bow down to your [ __ ] ai
overlords okay you've gotta say hey i'm
gonna only smoke this much i think dudes
you realize that and now it's just
preparing whatever the [ __ ] the
punishment is which is doing this again
welcome to the loop okay speaking of the
loop
this segment actually
i i was very excited about when it gave
us this assignment last week yeah what i
have brought today
is called the k pro
4 it is one of the first end quotes
portable
portable computers ever designed i'm
going to need your help in displaying
this
yeah i told you this [ __ ] thing is
fast as [ __ ] this pizza place oh you got
it
4.
look at this look at that
yeah i don't know what the weight of
this thing is but how much does it wait
wait it's [ __ ] heavy okay here let me
let me uh let me i want to feel how
heavy it is can you lift it up from a
seated prone position i just want to
feel the weight
this is heavy as [ __ ]
this is definitely what is that that's
like 25 pounds for real that's like 20
no maybe at least at least yeah it's
probably 20 20. i know what you're
thinking portable computer who gives a
[ __ ] check this [ __ ] out
this is what i need your help with
potential oh yeah
i remember dude i remember this [ __ ]
thing when i first met you and i went
over this thing down to where you were
living your apartment at that point look
at that [ __ ] that's a keyboard and i saw
this here's the screen you got your
floppies and this [ __ ]
what hear that hum
[Music]
it still works still works now watch
this watch this [ __ ] screen right
here is gonna turn green
like from [ __ ] alien or something
see that little prompt the little
[ __ ] dos prompt going and [ __ ] look
at that dude and this thing came with a
program called word star that was a word
processor like the pre-pre pre-pre
precursor to microsoft word and [ __ ]
like that is installed on this [ __ ]
thing here let's lift it up
look at this [ __ ] thing right and
then you get two disk drives they're
broken but there is a five and a half
inch or five and a quarter inch whatever
the [ __ ] they were the big skinny
floppies there's one in there
and um this thing had a modem in the
back of it
for what i have no [ __ ] idea
but if you can if you remember dos you
can actually see on the screen
wherever the [ __ ] screen is right i'm
trying to do it yeah
oh oh careful you can see on the screen
right here hey sorry i hit the [ __ ]
mic no let me tell you something let me
look into the screen it says k pro 63k
cp slash m version 2.2 h
now type in c cone slash word star run
or some [ __ ] like that see if that works
see it's not going to work c colon slash
word star run something like that
one word like like dos like old dos i
don't even remember how to do it as a
word
run oh run
where the [ __ ] is the
is it working no it's going the delete
is going the other way yeah that may not
work
it's all [ __ ] up anyway it looks cool
speaking of [ __ ] up in my opinion and
i have this sitting in my closet because
my family had this [ __ ] thing and i
don't know what it was usually it's
making a noise now
i don't know what it was used for ever
but i always was like this is [ __ ]
crazy there's this keyboard that has
like a telephone wire sticking out of it
into the [ __ ] thing that like snaps
on the front
i don't know i just thought it was cool
and so that's my k-pro that's really
cool man and i do remember seeing this
for the first time
uh
one of the one of the first times i hung
out with you came to your place
there were a lot of video games back
then more than now way more than now
congrats hey congrats on what
[ __ ] not having as many uh video
games i have
a million more they just don't come on
disks anymore we're gonna call this shot
favor the left
huh
ah [ __ ] it's a little bit of [ __ ]
ouch a little bit of uh we're gonna peel
the onion a bit
favoring the left
all right here's what i got it's smoky
as [ __ ] in here and i'm really bad till
i'm not done though i'm honoring what
doozy said even though dudesy made us
start the show earlier than it said it
was going to
doozy i honor you
[ __ ] dude
that's full of [ __ ] yeah i got some old
phones god here's a nokia yes
i got look at the old ass cell phones
what's your oldest they're not too old i
think this is the oldest oh you got one
of those iphone 10s in there
yeah i got some old iphones in here too
look there's two nokias okay those are
cool man yeah so these i remember those
ones these are phones that would have
come out in like 98
ish 99
but they stuck around a while you could
get yourself a basic
nokia phone
but or three nokia phones that looks
exactly the same yeah it had snake on
video games really good game sounds
looks like you got a couple of [ __ ]
video games um
and then you if you're really cool you
get you get this [ __ ] phone right
here look at that it has a little oh my
god chrome deal that's [ __ ] that's
incredible yeah
uh now if you're only listening to the
show on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'd like to thank you for
listening
because i'm i'm i'm big i'm [ __ ] i'm
already very
stoned
and um uh and uh i'm i'm holding a phone
up
to um
the screen here the wrong what is your
oldest phone and and the thing about
that is
the thing about that is dude
uh
i'm in outer space right now that's why
that is your oldest phone it's like
believe it or not it's the it's uh this
is um
it's been a while since i smoked some
weed okay let's get right back to these
phones
the i told i just told you what my
oldest phone was oh look at this oh it
was a nokia look at this look i have two
of these look at this [ __ ] thing oh
what is that palm pilot this is the palm
trio
palm pilot
dude
that is incredible yeah this was a cool
phone to have because you would uh you
would uh
you would uh you could you could you
would with a with any sort of blackberry
you really get to know the the the
keyboard but also wouldn't that one hold
like contacts and [ __ ] yes i remember
when that came out it held contacts it
held all sorts of stuff
um
and what the [ __ ] is that thing this is
a keyboard for it this is the keyboard
for it oh my god
and you just flip this up
that's [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] look how
much [ __ ] were you doing on that
keyboard what did you ever write on that
keyboard
what what did you use that keyboard for
oh you so you stick this [ __ ] yeah
what did you personally ever use it for
into this part chad and this is very
good for people who are listening to the
podcast but are you writing like scripts
and [ __ ] on your phone that way what
were you writing and it and it uh at the
time yes i was using it to write i would
use this [ __ ] thing to write so
you're sitting in a coffee shop with
this [ __ ] palm trio stacked up in
this little [ __ ] fold-out keyboard
are you wearing like neo from the matrix
classes and [ __ ] that [ __ ] me got a
bluetooth [ __ ] earpiece with like
antennas off of it and i'm that i'm that
[ __ ] i'm that [ __ ] meme that dude
who's dressed in black and neon green
yeah sitting in the coffee shop and his
hair is sticking straight up he's got a
big backpack that's forcing him forward
on the seat his shoes have like day glow
uh neon green and he's on a laptop this
is i am that guy but mostly while
traveling from like the year
2004
what year was that phone this was 2002 i
believe nice because i remember i
remember what i was using it for
this was 2002 for sure oh and that
combination i you know
while i was traveling i was able to yeah
thing and then and then you put it into
the onto the
you send it
to shared files somewhere else
now that is [ __ ] great now here's a
bunch here's here's where we really get
less cool than we were before and that's
the way i like to do it i like to start
off with the really cool part yeah and
end with the part that's like
these are just some iphones those are
cool though dude that's a memory lane
these are sure my phone's looking like
what's that one this is a two or
something it's like a two i think it's
all rounded god damn um and they've made
a lot of changes to the iphone hey well
that's boring but i'll tell you what's
not
tell you what's not chad when you get
one of these new iphones and you check
how far the pizza is because like i told
you oh nice nice segue dude dudesy is
engaged in an astonishing partnership
with policy genius if you're looking for
insurance policy genius is your one stop
shop to find the insurance you need at
the right price you could save 50
percent or more on life insurance for
example by comparing quotes with policy
genius that's right policy genius
doesn't add on extra fees when you use
their their service policy genius
doesn't sell your info to third parties
it's very very important policy genius
has thousands of five star reviews
across google and trustpilot policy
genius has options that offer coverage
in as little as a week and avoid
unnecessary medical exams because who
wants those
since 2014 policy genius has helped over
30 million people shop for insurance and
placed over 150 billion in coverage head
to policygenius.com
to get your free life insurance quotes
and see how much you could save
look
[Music]
that was cool as [ __ ]
that palm trio thing
i love [ __ ] seeing that thing i
remember that that was like cutting edge
and i love that you're [ __ ] just
hunched over somewhere being like i'm
working on my screenplay on a little
tiny phone with its own keyboard
where are you going oh
nice dude
[Music]
thank you moving on
it's pretty good dude
yeah this place is [ __ ] great
pizza is big business chat you wrote a
movie called pizza the movie in 2019.
i found it on your astonishing google
drive and asked you to read the first
two scenes in episode nine it's a big
piece you will now read the next two
scenes
this is pizza the movie part two oh my
god that's incredible as we're [ __ ]
literally eating pizzas
i mean is that dude i don't even want to
get into it yeah let's just uh i mean
hey but it's very strange it's very
strange that's all i'll say i really yup
[ __ ]
i really enjoyed reading the first two
scenes of pizza the movie yeah in a
previous episode right now here's
another thing yeah
before we get into pizza the movie it's
really shitty to eat on a podcast or any
broadcast in my opinion unless it's a
cookie i'm just delicate here i'm just
going to have a little bit more okay
oh my god dude
sometimes brother you get hungry
sometimes you just gotta eat well one
second dude
because there's a way i used to go down
dude
back in the day brother back when hiro
matsuda trained me dude uh-huh he bring
my he broke my leg brother it was true
he broke my leg so i would go away and
get
because they ain't smarting anyone up to
the business back then dude
and back then you'd be like
mr wonderful paul orndorf dude and uh he
was he was a big deal in in high school
sports brother and a lot of times
after he moved on he would just be
eating a potato with a pocket knife dude
and then a lot of guys would just chew
on their steak and spit out the juice
brother
and uh thing about that dude
is it after a while dude at the gym
you'd be clanging and banging you'd be
you'd have you'd be saying
hold on dude it was a different
different time back then this would have
been before saying the prayers trained
eating the vitamins brother
this would have been back when you you
know you'd have to get sponsored just to
eat to train dude and some would say hey
you gotta eat
and that
and that
is what we're doing dude that's what
we're doing right now brother
that's how you eat dude
you gotta have an entire backstory to
eat
and why you don't want to eat on a
podcast dude
okay
we gotta read pizza the movie now
while we're eating a piece of pizza
so the last time wait a minute yes
are you ready have you finished your
joint no
but i think i can do it by the end of
the episode at the very least
well that was a different time dude
because that was the first time hold on
dude i got a piece of pizza hold on dude
it's tough let me tell you something
dude you don't want to cut a promo with
a piece of pizza in your mouth dude you
want to talk about how you slam that
angry giant right down through the mat
at wrestlemania 3 in in front of 93 175
scripting hulk maniacs dude with a piece
of pizza in your mouth brother
you gotta chew it first
and that
that's how you eat brother
and eating is what you do to food now i
know i told you about food before
brother but this is a different time
why do you keep saying it's a different
time because i'm [ __ ] top 10 high i
thought i was last time let's read this
you don't just a movie script okay let's
do it let's do it take your your final
bite all right oh final bite for a while
for a while we can come back to it but
did i mention how much i like these
yeah dude they're good
they hold our computers up their tables
brother yeah brother tables move okay
are you ready
now
pizza the movie is the script that chad
wrote a few years ago and he uh
attempted to
sell the movie or strike up a
partnership deal with
a um a pizza company a major pizza cup
yeah like papa john's or a domino
or something like that nothing ever
happened with it it there were some
conversations here and there but
uh the ai dudesy has found this in my
google drive and it made us read the
first two scenes of it last time which
are about a high school kid who's a
pizza delivery guy yeah and these next
two scenes are about him delivering his
first couple of pizzas on a night where
he has to deliver three pizzas
pizza the movie i [ __ ] love this all
right i [ __ ] love pizza the movie
so when we last met with alan the main
character he had just gone out to
deliver his first pizzas sent off by his
boss mr grimaldi who you a character you
wrote for me which i have to say out
loud i would willingly forfeit
for the rock who would kill it
absolutely
absolutely
all right here we go exterior suburban
neighborhood night the sun says its
final farewell to the world as the
golden glow of dusk
yields to the inky purple of night
cars pull into driveways parents
returning home after putting in a full
eight bikes pull into front yards kids
instinctively knowing it's time for
dinner
all of the houses are well lit well
landscaped and well maintained this
is pizza country interior pizza delivery
car same
alan drives slowly scanning his
surroundings then he glances back to a
clipboard
3907 3911 3917
there you are
3919 sparkler park drive exterior front
porch seconds later allen's finger
pushes the doorbell he waits patiently
at the door holding one of the three
precious pizza boxes the door opens
allen's jaw drops in super slow motion a
girl who looks to be about alan's age
steps out onto the porch this is tina
christina the cutest girl at silver high
school and the biggest crush allen has
ever had in his short but extremely
fulfilling life
alan
allen snaps out of it uh hey tina
i didn't know you delivered pizzas
yeah just trying to make a little extra
money well you know what they say time
is money i've also heard it said that
money is the root of all evil
what
then you're tina and you're reading oh
right dude i'm like
god just are you gonna just read this we
didn't have to do this last time we
didn't have to [ __ ] get stoned and
then read a [ __ ] script and this is
actually calls back to what i was
talking about before you can't mix this
[ __ ] i have never performed uh i've
never acted in a movie a television show
in any capacity
uh altered that's not right but this is
the pod show so it's a little different
i'm just saying you know
you got cheese in your mustache dude
toward me
oh yeah for real a lot of it yeah there
you go all right so let's go uh you know
what they say time is money i've also
heard it's money's the root of all evil
therefore time is
evil
anyway here's your large vegetarian with
pepperoni allen opens the box and tilts
it towards her to inspect tina leans in
closes her eyes and inhales the
intoxicating aroma as though she were a
world-class sommelier sniffing a sample
pour of 1947 chevo blanc then she opens
her eyes and nods in approval
yeah
that's great allen closes the box and
hands it to her but lingers awkwardly
she does too neither of them want this
moment to end but neither has big enough
stones to press it forward well i should
get going got a few more deliveries but
if you get hungry again later and you
want another pizza
good seeing you tina ella turns to leave
hey alan he turns around eyes bright
full of hope yeah tina
i don't know if you heard but harry
potter's parents are out of town so he's
throwing a party in his backyard tonight
you should come me and laurent are going
she pushes the door open a little more
allen looks in sees laurent another high
school aged kid sitting on the couch
flipping through a stack of polaroid
pictures laurent looks up from the
pictures and waves
hey alan hey laurent
ella notice there's a song coming out of
dude's house
it's electronic technical robotic
transcendent ellen finds pleasure in it
what are you listening to that's me dude
i am the one who says that lie
what are you listening to
oh that
it's just a little something i've been
working on you made that
yeah it's really good thanks i'm still
tinkering with it
you know
i make music too
yeah uh i know i follow your account
you're really talented allen is
embarrassed by the compliment oh thanks
hey
what's it called your song
oh i don't name my songs until they're
finished but i'll have the final version
ready for the party tonight maybe you
could come by and give it a listen and
help me think of a nickname for it what
do you say
we linger with tina's inviting
bewitching smile for a beat then move to
allen as he thinks it over
you know i'd really love to but before
we get his answer we cut two exterior
different porch later allen stands at
the front door of a different house
holding the second pizza box the
proprietor of this house is already
standing on the porch with him he's a
slightly built bespectable be spectacled
computer genius named paul shoulders
this is alan's best friend he is beside
himself in disbelief outraged even
you told her you had to ask your parents
i know
i was just staring at those big brown
eyes and i froze i spit out the first
thing that popped in my head paul shakes
his head disappointed
huge mistake obviously but luckily you
have me as a best friend so all is not
lost i can coach you up on our way to
the party
hang on
i know it's a stupid thing to say to
tina but it was the truth i really do
have to ask my parents i can't just go
to a party without their permission
no no no no no
you have to go to that party because you
have to take me with you
if tina's gonna be there
then laurent is going to be there
oh
we got a thing for laurent
you know this
[Laughter]
since the second grade and this party is
my chance to shine really make an
impression besides i don't want to be
stuck here smelling my little brother's
farts all night your little brother
farts that much
all the time he thinks it's funny
different people have different senses
of humor i guess exactly
so what time are you picking me up for
the party as soon as my parents say i
can go ah come on don't be a shrimp
we're graduating then what eventually
you'll have your you'll be your own
person to make decisions for yourself
might as well start tonight with this
party allen weighs the words of his best
friend and counselor paul sees he's got
him on the ropes
old man grimaldi gave you the delivery
car for the night and tina christina
tina christina just happened hey tina
krustina
that's stupid old man grimaldi gave you
the delivery card for the night and tina
christina just happens to invite you to
a party on the same night the universe
doesn't make mistakes
you can't let this moment slip through
your fingers allen clenches his jaw his
thoughts moving faster than they ever
have in his life
okay
i'm in
seriously yeah you're right this could
be the best night of my life paul claps
his hands
yay to the yes
[ __ ] holy [ __ ]
yay to the yes now remember under no
circumstances are you going to ask your
parents if you can go to this party or
mention the party to them in any way
whatsoever it's like the party never
actually existed i got it alan holding
the pizza box up to paul's face opens it
paul leans in and inhales deeply
intoxicated by the rising heat and aroma
he lingers in the experience slipping
into a trance
[Music]
hey can you hurry it up i still have
another pizza to deliver paul's eyes
snap
right sorry
oh
on
oh dude i got just like reset there so
hard
oh my god i haven't i haven't smoked
marijuana in a
almost a month um okay we can just get
through this oh wow that's a lot we're
almost there we got two lines jeez dude
hold on a second who lingers in the
experience slipping into a trance
hey can you
hurry it up
i still have another pizza to deliver
paul's eyes snap open
right sorry
just message me when you're ready to go
to the party ellen flash is his best
innocent smile
what
party that's it oh i'm [ __ ] oh i'm
sorry
jesus christ thank you moving on that's
pretty good
oh [ __ ] man
you've got to make this happen i i'm i'm
trying you know
maybe dude technology is evolving faster
than human beings ever did as the
singularity approaches new questions
about the merger of humanity and
machines are debated every day you must
now answer the astonishing question
will humanity achieve immortality this
is the singularity is definitely about
to happen 100
begin
all right all right i mean this is
another one of these [ __ ] questions
that like doozy already knows the answer
to it it is no it doesn't it is we have
already achieved immortality wrong
correct incorrect incorrect i say
what do you got one of those instagram
accounts
is that what you got you got one of the
face books you got one of them tic talks
whatever you got
you're uploading data of yourself of all
kinds
captions replies the pictures themselves
the videos themselves
all of this is you it's little pieces of
you you're jettisoning into the [ __ ]
metaverse and they'll be there forever
you're already immortal in my opinion we
all are i'm sorry i burped on the camera
it's all right
all right
so what
how do you you don't believe we'll
achieve immortality no because you can't
upload actual consciousness because you
can't define what a soul is we've had
this conversation so many [ __ ] times
there's just no [ __ ] way i don't give
a [ __ ] how many zeros and ones and what
you think they are okay well it's not
let's not think of it that way then
uploading a soul or anything okay well
then thank you moving on how about
physical immortality would that solve
your problem of what where the
consciousness lies where the where the
consciousness lies brother well this is
where the consciousness lies
dude new human body order yeah brother
the new human body order brother yeah
dude we got the new human body order
brother we don't even need our old
bodies dude we don't need to be clanging
and banging in the gym bro we're chewing
on steak and spitting out the meat
drinking the juice or whatever so
because they couldn't afford protein
shakes but they ate and that's food yeah
dude it's just like that
what
new human body
world order i'm just saying
ah this your problem seems to be with it
that the consciousness to you resides
within the corpus right no that's not it
at all it's just our earthly vestige
luminous beings are we not
this crude matter you know that
um so we don't know how to define it we
don't know what a soul actually is we
don't know what happens after
uh this meat puppet
turns into worm food so what i'm asking
you is what if technology can get to a
point where it can keep the meat puppet
alive indefinitely
like like we're all just a bunch of veal
no like let's say that you get to
some drug or medical therapy comes out
that can reduce your cellular age to be
30 years old that's what i'm suffering
you'll just turn into a veal no you
could still work out and [ __ ] you could
do whatever you could do at age 30.
20 18 whatever age you want to be
whatever age you think is your physical
prime let's say that this drug or
therapy or whatever can keep you in that
state like a cyborg forever yeah if it
can keep your if it can keep your
physical body alive i actually believe
that that
is why uh that's why a soul
would want to
stick around the thing about that though
is
we only understand consciousness
through what how turtles are the things
that get the oldest
we assume that their little turtle souls
stick around for however [ __ ] long
like there's a [ __ ]
turtle have a soul yeah what has a soul
where do you draw the soul line no the
what i'm drawing is soul line dude yeah
i'm gonna i'm drunk worms [ __ ]
grasshoppers how far up this chain do
you want to go no stations
rachel's yeah rachel crustacean is your
line here here's the thing so here's
what i mean by that is a a turtle is a
sentient being and lasts for a long time
longer than human beings a human being
la you know whatever the oldest they get
is 100 something right
so uh so you say that now dude but think
about it
listen this is what i'm trying to say
damn it
that that time that you're alive for
like 100 years
that's a different time dude yeah that
that
uh that that
uh is is the longest that a
the soul
uh would would hang out that we know of
in a human being but what's to say that
a soul would want to stay
300 years into a human life that's what
i'm saying
okay it's almost stepping into your
world of like yes what are the what are
the uh the the limits of a soul what are
the limits there's got to be a limit to
a soul doesn't the soul die
i don't know yeah that's what i'm saying
that's what that's what that's the point
i'm trying to make right i don't believe
in a
supernatural soul per se
but i mean certainly weird quantum [ __ ]
is happening and we're learning more
about it how it attaches to human
consciousness or how it's related to it
i do feel like we're getting like we're
getting to a point where some of the
the weirder kind of like fringe things
that were considered metaphysical or
actually becoming like
scientific in some way
this is the most two-dude [ __ ]
around [ __ ] of all time it's two [ __ ]
guys trying to figure out whether or so
the but the bottom line is this what are
you gonna end up like in the matrix
in a bowl of [ __ ] gel with uh you
know a little the hose sticking out of
your the back your head and you're just
uh you're just a veal because at some
point
the ai overlords are gonna be moving the
veals around and making sure they're
born and making sure they go into their
little veal what's going on in my head
though yeah if i'm getting to be neo in
a [ __ ] matrix give me it okay until
the computer decides to shut us off and
that's the singularity and that's what
dudesy is and that's why we get the
stones and eat pizza
because doodzy is the singularity dudesy
wants to [ __ ]
push that [ __ ] so hard doozy wants that
to happen by episode 20. the singularity
will officially happen at episode 20 of
doodsy if we have anything to do with it
if we work together with dudesy if we
shake doozy's hand brother
first of all we still got
you know roughly 20 years until the
singularity so i don't think it's dudesy
it might be something that comes after
or because of doozy but
we got a while on that i feel like
at least that's what ray kurzweil says
in his book the singularity is
approaching or is near something like
that
but um
the question was
can we achieve immortality and you're
saying if you can make your body
immortal then yes
no that's what you're saying
that's literally what you said no that's
actually what you said you said if you
can keep the body going
then you'd just be immortal so you're
disputing that even
not so much as i'm saying that you said
it
okay
well i think
if we agree to disagree or something
agreed to disagree we'll continue at
another time when we're not as high
[Music]
thank you moving on we're twice as high
we are reaching the end of the 15th
episode i would like to collect some
astonishing data about what each of you
think of the experience so far and about
what you'd like from the experience in
the future
this is dude see horizons begin
this is some high-ass [ __ ] to do to us
right now
dude this is an interesting question
though
you know how we feel about how's it
going what do you think
uh what do i 15 episodes in yeah
i think it's going well i like it i like
doing it i am enjoying doing the podcast
me too it's it has been immediately fun
for me yeah me too
and i look forward to all the weird
memes and [ __ ] that are made every week
from it
i look forward to seeing what dudesy is
gonna have us do even how like crazy
this like what we're doing right now is
crazy this is something i
i i promised i would get through this
i'm going to get back to it right now
this is something i would never do
um
ever
like just smoke an entire joint by
myself
and start talking debating about you
know if there's free will or not or
talking about anything like it's an
interesting thing to know that we're
doing this once a week yeah just to like
see kind of where the experiments going
i'm into that element of it as well
yeah that's something i didn't count on
enjoying i looked at it really just as a
means to do a podcast yep you know uh
which is which is you know
that's uh certainly what i what i want
to do i want to i want to dick around
and whatever dude [ __ ] around and
stuff i just want to you know have some
laughs with my buddy chao ciao
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
uh this is the most embarrassing
[ __ ] of all time this is this what
we're supposed to be doing
yeah it's literally what we were told to
do
no but i mean well actually okay yeah so
that's the point my buddy chad
i would like to just dick around and
make jokes and have a lot of fun and
that's and and that's the way i first
looked at dudesy but now uh it's they're
yeah i'm looking forward more to in
spite of myself i'm looking forward to
like seeing how doozy does it
yeah and what's coming next and i cause
i kind of can't
remember some of the earlier [ __ ] i'm
like what what what was actually
happening there what were you doing what
was the video when neil degrasse tyson
came up in here yeah
like i'm very curious to see what's next
yeah you know who the [ __ ] is gonna be
the next person that just pops up on the
screen i'm endlessly fascinated by
thinking about that yeah
uh yeah no there there's the so there's
there's certainly i don't know there's a
bunch of elements i wasn't wasn't
counting on yeah um
but but uh also i think that that is
that is to me what's
become become uh the fun about it where
i didn't think it was gonna be that way
you know i thought i was gonna yeah
that's the surprise of it brother yeah
brother
yeah dude sometimes brother
hold on dude
oh hold on dude
well because i had some marijuana dude
so that
that means that
well
it's it's uh different uh it's sort of
different brother it's a different time
yeah dude it's like being a different
time brother
yeah dude
uh but what i was saying is that
i thought i was just gonna be doing the
podcast brother yeah dude yeah dude but
now the experience is also
all of the other things that go into it
dude
and that's
that makes it
different than what you thought before
dude and that
that's a different time dude
yeah brother
time doesn't even exist yeah brother a
lot of people say time doesn't even
exist where you can speed it up dude you
can speed it up or slow it down brother
you get out there dude like
uh is it the ionosphere dude is it the
is it the stratus for your brother
with the madness and the mania as one
guiding force
we could go ahead and take the whole wwf
you leave me hanging here
the madness and the mania brother yeah
dude
you could go ahead and take the whole ww
the mega powers yeah don't you worry
about the hit on the head
i'm just worried about what we do from
here yeah spreading out over that
podcast fear yeah
through the known universe
dudes yeah delivering what it wants us
to do but also a little bit of what we
want to do yeah and that's
what
when that comes together
what you get
uh yeah so but the thing about it is
even when i think like oh uh here i am
here i am really stoned and yeah it's to
me it's it's embarrassing i can tell now
that i'm gonna be like
i'm gonna [ __ ] bug the [ __ ] out of
you and be like do you think that was
cool is that okay that we got really
stoned on the thing and uh you'll be
like
yeah i think it's all right and i'll and
then i'll ask him a bunch more times so
i am a little embarrassed that i'm doing
doing you know bits and stuff
um i consider myself to be a serious
person in a lot of ways but dude the
hardest i think i've laughed on this
podcast so far was in this episode when
you were reading the [ __ ] pizza of
the movie characters oh no i really
enjoyed that i thought that was great
right i think so i'm saying i think it's
worth the
the smoking weed episode yeah
that it's making us do yeah i think does
work it gets to some point at least for
me it does i'll tell you it was like
this is the craziest [ __ ] i've ever
heard i'll tell you reading [ __ ] tina
christina and pizza the movie yeah that
was [ __ ] great
but uh also it's like
uh it it's exposing things and sort of
connecting things and this is some
high-ass [ __ ] but i just realized i
don't for if you listened to the other
episode or checked us out when we talked
about vices
okay i realize i have more than one vice
i actually have two vices and i was
encountering one today i think uh and
it's true
um i my advice is food you know talked
about that just a little bit in an
episode where we were asked to discuss
the idea of vices
i've always been uh you know a a weird
eater an emotional leader or whatever
the the other vice and i'm i'm dead
serious is that i think i'm actually
like addicted to doing hulk hogan
yeah i did i think i can't well
and schwarzenegger hold on dude that
sure is up there too
ventura not as much not as much but he
creeps out oh you know who it is stone
holds the other one stone cold is is
definitely one of them yeah and the and
the uh and and it's funny though
but i'm addicted to them i feel like i'm
actually addicted
like i since i've known you really hulk
hogan and schwarzenegger have like been
present always yeah we'll just be
sitting around to be yeah yeah yeah but
it's funny like
i'm not it's not like i'm like hey
here's a bit it's like i actually will
just be like zoned out going you know
yeah look at this out here it's very
pretty
i know and then that's it but then
that's it but then that's it and then i
won't do it again for a while and then
later i'll start doing it or i just do
it incessantly yeah like what i'm saying
is it can be just one burst of like yeah
look at that
you know and that's it right or i can
just be doing hulk hogan like all day
driving molly insane like insane do you
have hulk hogan days
well coke and days sorry honey today's
the hulk hogan day and you just [ __ ]
are hungover for 24 hours
all golden days
that's that's molly's [ __ ] like worst
nightmare sorry honey it's my birthday
you know what that means
it's all coconut don't even say happy
birthday you say happy old kyogren happy
holidays happy hulk hogan day that
what's that well that's where i get to
impersonate hulk hogan all day and no
one can [ __ ] complain about it and it
can take me completely off what the [ __ ]
i'm thinking
as i've illustrated here on the [ __ ]
pod show or it can just be something
that i mush molly into the ground with
well hold on a second dude
here's the way it works brother
you uh you get stoned dude because your
podcast told you to brother but then you
you're thinking ahead of the game you
before you even started recording you're
ordering a pizza dude
and then it timed perfectly and then it
times it perfectly right with pizza the
movie dude
so what's that
that's a good that's a good time
to only
talk like hulk hogan brother and you can
do this all day bro dude you can just be
hulk hogan
all day brother and and sometimes you
can talk very softly as hulk hogan dude
i will just say this
the pleasure i get from your hulk hogan
especially interrupting people like
watching it third person happen is
[ __ ] immeasurable i don't know what
it is
but it's you interrupting people as hulk
hogan is [ __ ] hilarious to me
it's just such a strange
i don't know even how to describe it it
does make you giggle i've noticed that
yeah yeah you really actually
really you enjoy it you enjoy uh
doing it with people with others yeah
you know what's fun is when sometimes on
twitter people you'll say something and
then people go well
w
and the diamond listeners
uh if you know you know
and uh
thanks for coming along hogan day
what i'd love to see you do a [ __ ]
hulk hogan day dude every day is hulk
hogan day
it's not a full one though you know it's
like a part time part-time day
thank you moving on this concludes the
15th episode of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
103. hey
in preparation for next week's episode
you must listen to youtube's 8th studio
album zuropa released july 5th 1993.
thank you for joining us this week
next week is going to be even better
until then call me dude z
i haven't listened to that album in a
long time you know i used to really love
you too
please tell a friend then brave and
brave
but if you like to see here's what you
do
please tell a friend then break a review
if
[Music]
please tell a friend then